life is sales you sell yourself to your
partner you sell yourself to your
children you sell yourself at your job
you sell yourself to your boss you sell
yourself to your clients all of us are
constantly selling especially those of
you that think you're not and there's
one way to sell anything to anybody it's
the oldest trick in the book and it's
not a trick it's a way of living your
life build trust how do you build trust
commit to something deliver on it
communicate effectively and make sure
that everything you say you're going to
do you do and if you can't that you
communicate up front this is an age-old
wisdom it's probably not going to Trend
this video you're not going to share it
a million times with your friends cuz it
sounds common sense you know the crazy
thing about living in the world in 2023
is the common things are just not so
common anymore you want to stand out
build trust do the simple things really
really well